[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 j
- 3 avant les élections au Brésil
dimanche plus de 156 millions de
Brésiliens vont élire leur président
mais aussi les députés les gouverneurs
et un tiers des sénateurs pour le
premier tour de la présidentielle malgré
une multitude de candidatures la
campagne se résume un peu à un duel
entre l'ancien président Louis inazio
Lula da Silva et le chef d'État sortant
jaillir bolsonaro en tête des sondages
Lula affirme qu'il veut sauver le Brésil
d'une dictature d'extrême droite gear
bolsonaro menace quant à lui de ne pas
respecter les urnes si les rouges je
cite et les corrompus accèdent au
pouvoir bref tous deux ont des
personnalités clivantes il s'opposent en
économie en politique internationale le
match ou la bolsonaro et bien c'est le
sujet de ce soir et on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Sylvia akapanema bonsoir vous êtes
historienne spécialiste du Brésil à
l'université Sorbonne Paris Nord
conseillère départementale de la
Seine-Saint-Denis à côté la France
insoumise bienvenue à vous en face de
vous Virginie Jacques Auberger l'avouer
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du Brésil aux échos auteurs
de Brésil voyage au pays de bolsonaro et
c'est sorti en 2021 voilà superbe
couverture tout à fait en tout cas dans
le sujet merci d'être là avec nous
également François Michel detourneau
bonsoir géographe spécialiste du Brésil
directeur de recherche au CNRS bienvenue
à vous en face de vous gaspardestrada
bonsoir directeur exécutif de l'opalc
l'observateur politique de l'Amérique
latine et des Caraïbes et c'est à
Sciences Po bonsoir à vous également les
derniers sondages donnent il faut le
dire une avance une avance certaine à
Lula sur bolsonaro mais bien sûr rien
n'est joué retour sur le match de deux
personnalités clivantes avec Laura Cambo
tout oppose Lula ancienne ouvrier
métallurgiste et syndicaliste se posent
en défenseur des pauvres des militants
LGBT et des indigènes nous voulons un
gouvernement qui nourrit l'amour
réserviste de l'armée de terre jaillir
bolsonaro cultive sa base les militaires
les industriels de l'agroalimentaire et
les Brésiliens évangéliques
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire a toujours montré que le bien
vaincra
le premier défi du président sera de
remettre sur pied l'économie du pays
frappé par la pandémie de covid et
l'inflation à deux chiffres l'une des
conséquences le retour de la fin au
Brésil 33 millions de personnes en
souffrent aujourd'hui directement dans
son programme l'ancien président de
gauche prône la fin de l'austérité ou
pas le pays que j'ai quitté est un pays
qui manque aux gens c'était un pays où
il y avait de l'emploi où les gens
avaient le droit de vivre dignement
veut taxer davantage les plus riches et
faire des investissements pour des
programmes sociaux et environnementaux
vision diamétralement opposée pour son
adversaire
ultra libéral
nous savons que le communisme mène au
malheur à la pauvreté à la fin et à la
misère
de la compétitivité il prévoit des
baisses d'impôts des privatisations
d'entreprise et une ligne budgétaire
très orthodoxe seul concession un
nouveau programme social pour remplacer
celui mis en place par son concurrent en
l'autre différence primordiale touche à
la sécurité Lula promet une politique de
lutte contre la drogue et le
démantèlement du crime organisé j'adhère
bolsonaro lui veut continuer à faire de
la libéralisation du port d'armes une
priorité sous sa présidence le nombre de
permis délivrés a été multiplié par 6
s'il faut se battre contre le gang de
Lula nous nous battrons
et je le répète le peuple armé ne sera
jamais asservi
une déclaration qui reflète l'escalade
de violence en deux ans les agressions à
caractère politique ont bondit de 23 %
dans ce contexte c'est la démocratie
même du pays qui est en jeu pour le
candidat du Parti des Travailleurs
nous devons travailler pour gagner le
vote de tous ceux qui aiment la
démocratie
depuis que Lola est en tête dans les
sondages Jahia bolsonaro remette en
cause le vote électronique un système
qui est pourtant utilisé au Brésil
depuis 1996
et on va écouter quelques électeurs tout
de suite
bolsonaro va gagner au premier tour
même si les sondages disent que Lula va
gagner ce que nous voyons dans la rue la
ferveur et l'acceptation que suscite le
président sont immenses
si les pauvres aujourd'hui entendent toi
deux ou trois téléviseurs c'est grâce à
Lula si tout le monde a un téléphone
portable et que chacun mange à sa fin
c'est grâce à Lola j'aime Louna j'ai
toujours voté pour lui même quand il a
perdu ce sera toujours là pour moi
jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
François Michel Le Tourneau pour bien
cadrer le débat tous les opposes ces
deux candidats en termes de profil de
programmes économique effectivement et
de rapport à la démocratie aussi il faut
bien le dire lorsqu'on va en être deux
petites fiches techniques on voit
d'abord Lula l'ouvrier metalos
syndicaliste avec ce slogan pour un
Brésil heureux à nouveau l'amour vaincra
la haine ça c'est Loula et son
colistiers il s'appelle Géraldo alcmin
il est un ténor de centre droit qui a
déjà été ministre bolsonaro lui son
slogan c'est Dieu patrie famille liberté
le Brésil au-dessus de tout Dieu
au-dessus de tous et son colistier c'est
le général Walter Braga Neto qui a un
des plus hauts gradés de l'armée
brésilienne est-ce qu'on peut dire que
ça reflète la société brésilienne
François Michel Letourneau justement
cette opposition ça me paraît difficile
comment dire bolsonaro est représentant
d'une partie de la société brésilienne à
peu près un tiers de l'électorat qui est
assez polarisé autour de lui mais je
pense que sur Loula il faut plutôt
insister plutôt que sur son passé de
syndicaliste qui est comme il y a assez
longtemps sur son rôle en tant que
président du Brésil Lula c'est le
président des jours heureux c'est le
président du Brésil qui s'est développé
considérablement qui a eu une très forte
croissance économique une amélioration
des conditions de vie de la population
et donc en fait c'est ça qu'on essaie de
redonner enfin c'est ce que Lula veut
proposer au peuple brésilien mais c'est
également un petit peu ce pourquoi on
l'a ramené au devant de la scène parce
que il a cet appel très très fort de
avant c'était mieux c'était un Brésil
heureux contre le Brésil polarisé divisé
qu'a proposé bolsonaro qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez à Virginie Jacob berger
l'avouer alors il est bolsonaro comment
le qualifier d'avant lui dit c'est la
mort ou la victoire
on a beaucoup dit à Andy c'est le Trump
des tropiques et franchement quand on
voit son électorat c'est les pro-arms
c'est des évangéliques c'est
l'agro-business donc on a vraiment un
parallélisme avec l'ex-président
américain qu'on trouve tout de suite
après c'est aussi le pur produit de la
politique brésilienne il est quand même
c'était un politicien de carrière 30 ans
députés en faisant passer en deux lois
donc c'était quand même pas le meilleur
politicien et donc c'est pas non plus le
même profil que Trump alors qu'on les a
quand même vraiment beaucoup on a
vraiment insisté sur sur le caractère
similaire ça fait longtemps qu'il est en
politique lui ça montre pas et en 30 ans
il a fait passer que de lois au départ
c'est un ancien militaire mais en fait
il y avait pas fait grand chose et donc
par opposition puisque vous disiez tout
à l'heure la question est-ce que c'est
le choc des titans oui je pense qu'on a
jamais vu une élection comme ça ou
effectivement il y a un candidat voilà
qui est le Trump entre guillemets
brésilien entre hommes des tropiques et
de l'autre côté on a Lula donc le
revenant c'est vraiment ça quelle
résurrection il était quand même
emprison il y a un an il a vaincu un
cancer personne s'attendait à ce qui
comme quoi en politique faut jamais dire
jamais parce que lui est de retour sur
la scène et lui c'est vraiment le
symbole du petit père des peuples mais
je pense qu'il faut aussi sortir
peut-être aussi un peu de simplement une
fois qu'on a dit ça il faut aussi voir
caler le Brésil ce que vous rappelez lié
tout à l'heure c'est vrai le mandat de
Lula il est parti avec un score de popul
priorité absolument phénoménale de à la
suite de son deuxième mandat pourquoi
parce que le Brésil était aussi dans un
contexte international tout à fait
différent il était en pleine croissance
derrière la Chine aujourd'hui le
contexte politique est malheureusement
effroyable donc il y a un héritage il y
a entre temps malheureusement il y a une
récession qui est celle des du temps de
Dilma de la gauche après il y a les
années catastrophiques du mandat
bolsonaro et aujourd'hui la campagne
elle va aussi se jouer dans un contexte
économique qui n'a rien à voir avec ce
qui se présentait précédemment c'est
bien capanimal alors effectivement on
vous parliez de Lula Lula ces années cet
âge d'or du Brésil et en même temps Lula
à un moment quand même derrière les
barreaux donc est-ce que le fait qu'il
ait été rattrapé par cette affaire
lavajato alors d'abord il a on l'a vu en
prison ensuite il a été il a été blanchi
par la Cour suprême est-ce que ça annule
tout de même à son image mais c'est très
utilisé par les opposants justement
pendant un certain moment ça c'était un
élément qui qui pouvait rendre préjudice
à son image mais actuellement et ça a
été pris dans les émissions il est
blanchi de toutes les accusations donc
les affaires de corruption aujourd'hui
et elles sont plus même du côté de
jaillebossonaro qui a deux ou trois
affaires de corruption qui sont qui sont
diffusés dans la presse donc une d'achat
de plus de 150 immeubles avec de
l'argent liquide par des membres de sa
famille d'autres affaires de corruption
de transfert d'argent dans le compte de
son épouse et d'autres affaires de des
liaisons avec les milices donc lui aussi
pour avoir corrompu sur sa tête comme
image je parle bolsonaro actuellement
avec ses affaires les affaires sont plus
la corruption la dénonciation de la
corruption elle est plus du côté de
bossonnas que de lui là qui sortent
totalement blanchi et même
si c'est un débat si je peux me
permettre je pense que quand même le
terme de blanchir en fait là il faut
quand même bien comprendre que la
justice brésilienne toutes les charges
contre Lula ça c'est tout à fait exact
ce que vous dites elles sont levées mais
il est pas blanchi dans le sens où la
justice la jamais innocenté donc il y a
quand même un problème
toutes les charges sont levées
et et en revanche ce que ce qui est vrai
c'est que le la corruption autour de
donc moi pour les échos récemment j'ai
fait toute une enquête sur le clan
bolsonaro sur les fils il faut voir que
pourquoi aussi il y a cette bataille
pourquoi bolsonaro veut garder le
pouvoir c'est que ce qui les attend si
perdre le pouvoir c'est des problèmes
avec des poursuites judiciaires parce
que tous les assembles un peu à Trump
alors exactement il rattrapé par des
problèmes de corruption et et des
problèmes graves
donc c'est pas rien blanchi pas blanchi
actuellement la Cour suprême ne
serait-ce que hier a publié à suspendu
une demande de la du fisc que brésilien
et à réaffirmé le caractère de
l'innocence de Lula et d'autant plus
je suis désolé
la question c'est pas Lola
en fait par rapport à Lola la question
n'est pas forcément
Lula lui-même c'est également les
affaires de corruption qui a eu lieu à
l'époque des gouvernement Lola et
notamment l'affaire du mince salon où
elle était montrée que le gouvernement
mis en place par Lula payé des
parlementaires pour faire passer ses
lois ce qui allias au Brésil est une
pratique tout à fait courante donc il a
jamais fait que faire ce que faisait
tous les autres mais lui il s'est fait
prendre avec les doigts dans le pot de
confiture donc Lula n'a pas été condamné
lui-même pour ça parce qu'on n'a jamais
trouvé l'épreuve mais il y a quand même
ça en arrière-plan donc voilà donc la
question de la corruption
risque rapidement d'arriver à quelque
chose qui est un peu un match nul
c'est-à-dire que de toute manière il y a
de la corruption de la vie politique
brésilienne et le pété n’y échappera
mandat de bolsonaro ça on est très on
est tout à fait d'accord
en revanche ce qu'on peut dire quand
même sur Lula c'est pas
un mot sur la troisième voie il y a
quand même d'autres candidats
effectivement on en parle très peu on
les connaît en flux très peu en France
et en Europe enfin d'une manière
générale même à l'international bon il y
a quand même un ancien ministre que
sirop Gomes et lui un peu dont on parle
le plus qui pourrait avoir un petit
pourcentage et une femme qui s'appelle
Simone tu es bête c'est ça un certain
nombre d'électeurs j'imagine vois aussi
voter pour elle parce que c'est une
femme même si non aucune chance pourquoi
est-ce que finalement on se polarise sur
deux candidats les autres on avait déjà
plus de chance déjà dès le départ enfin
bon je pense que la question centrale de
cette élection c'est que vous avez deux
comme la Virginie deux anciens un ancien
président et un président en exercice
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire en terme de
communication politique et de campagne
électorale c'est qu'il s'agit de deux
candidats qui sont très facilement
reconnaissables par la population et
c'est un lecteur de bolsonaro va pas
voter pour Lula et inversement donc de
ce fait donc c'est totalement polarisé
cristallisation l'électorat en fait qui
a été très précoce et cela a eu un
impact en fait sur la campagne
électorale parce qu'en fait les courbes
des intentions de vote dans quasiment
pas évolué depuis le début de la
campagne où là est en tête de cette
campagne depuis le début de l'année et
malgré les scandales malgré les
campagnes voilà peu de choses ont évolué
aussi pourquoi est-ce que Lula est en
tête malgré tout est-ce que bolsonaro a
payé par exemple la crise sanitaire
680000 morts au Brésil est-ce que sont
une partie de son électorat qui aurait
peut-être voté pour lui il y a 4 ans
justement à cause de cette crise
sanitaire et de toute sa démarche
anti-vax est-ce que ça aurait pénalisé
il y a la crise sanitaire mais il y a le
fait que le gouvernement bolsonaro est
en fait un vaste bazar c'est à dire que
il y a pas de ligne politique directrice
il a été obligé de s'allier avec tous
les partis qui voulaient bien s'allier
avec lui pour essayer d'avoir une
majorité au Congrès et c'est une
majorité vikevaille et donc en fait
notamment sur le plan économique ce qui
explique un peu le retournement des
milieux d'affaires c'est-à-dire que tout
ce qu'il avait promis en terme de grande
réformes libérales et d'avoir un Brésil
qui allait changer du tout au tout il
n'a rien réussi à faire passer au
Congrès donc au total on est
véritablement face à le loup là comme
j'ai dit le candidat des jours heureux
face aux candidats du désordre de
l'autre de l'autre côté justement à ce
sujet on va l'écouter sur la crise
sanitaire
Paulson
ça ne sera pas une petite grippe qui me
fera tomber d'accord
si le médecin du ministère de la Santé
me recommande un nouvel examen je le
passerai tout le monde s'en souvient
évidemment Sylvia Capanema ça sera
petite grippe ça il l'a quand même il a
payé il a pas plusieurs reprises donc
lui-même denier de ne pas vouloir porter
de masque et aujourd'hui même il dit que
le confinement était pas une bonne
mesure qu'il fallait pas prendre des
mesures de confinement parce que ça
détruisait à l'économie et même il est
en étude de l'université de s'en parle
ou qui montre que non seulement il n'a
pas agi pour bloquer l'avancée de
l'épidémie comme il a agit pour
exterminer les personnes les plus
fragiles dans la société brésilienne à
travers sa conduite de la pandémie il
faut savoir que le Brésil a un système
de santé que pour ce genre de campagne
de vaccination fonctionne très bien et
pour d'autres campagnes de prévention
des épidémies des maladies fonctionne
très bien et le Brésil aurait pu éviter
et selon
une partie 3/4 ou la moitié de ces 700
000 morts et ça ça va peser contre ça va
être une des charges en plus contre
Jacques brossola parce que tout le monde
a vécu dans leur famille à l'expérience
d'avoir expliqué en partie la popularité
de Lula face à
moi je pense que vraiment la pandémie au
contraire moi je pense que ça jouait
énormément dans la campagne et avec
raison parce que 680 ça c'est les
chiffres officiels c'est sans doute plus
on est peut-être à 700000 morts du covid
dans une population certes de 215
millions mais quand on sait que la le
Brésil a une population jeune c'est
juste impardonnable ça veut dire que
rien n'a été fait dans effectivement un
Brésil qui avait quand même des moyens
de vaccination des mêmes moyens
sanitaires qui existaient
on reproche au gouvernement il serait
responsable à peu près de 400 000 morts
donc et les 700 donc presque 700 000
morts faut se dire que dans l'esprit des
Brésiliens moi je pense encore en
revanche que le boomerang du résultat de
la manière dont il a géré effroyablement
cette crise sanitaire c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle il a un vote
contre lui parce que c'est un peu comme
les héros vous savez grec parce que il y
a quand même un côté populaire au Brésil
c'est le principe de katabase un moment
donné la personne là puisque lui il se
prend pour un mythe et tout faut
descendre dans la reine et parler aussi
des morts et et quand il est confronté à
ça en fait lui il était dans le total
des nids la seule fois où il a reconnu
le fait qu'il y a eu qu'il a mal géré la
pandémie c'est il y a quelques jours au
début des débats donc c'est quand même
incroyable ce déni de réalité quoi c'est
vraiment pour moi la caractéristique des
populistes à la Trump c'est pareil c'est
nié la réalité et et quand on regarde le
mandat de bolsonaro ce qui est
incroyable c'est que c'est pas un
président qui a gouverné c'est un
président qui a divisé qui n'a cessé de
faire que diviser son peuple
gaspardestrada ça expliquerait donc en
partie cette avance de Lula sur lui
cette mauvaise gestion de la crise
sanitaire oui parce que en perspective
justement le bilan de LOA il est bon et
donc les Brésiliens
le Brésil avait une croissance de 7,5%
du donc on est très loin de cette
croissance de l'époque et donc justement
Lula joue sur ce bilan pour promettre un
avenir meilleur et comme le la vie
actuelle est aussi
négative triste avec une société
extrêmement polarisée bah il est il est
clair que
l'espoir alors qu'il a passé tout ce
temps dans la vie politique puisqu'elle
a été en prison il incarne une
opposition et de donc de ce point de vue
là c'est ce qui explique que ce succès
un petit point sur ce clivage il faut
quand même se rappeler que Bolson run a
été élu en 2018 que parce que Lula a été
disqualifié donc de ce point de vue là
en fait le rôle de sauveur de Lula était
déjà là avait déjà été armée avant avec
justement la grande difficulté du Parti
des travailleurs et des parties de
gauche du Brésil c'est qui après Lula
terre comment on fait qui a 76 ans et
qui sera pas éternel ne sera plus
fonctionnel comme futur président
parce que il y a effectivement il est
populaire c'est khalila il a des
supporters mais il a aussi une partie de
la population qui aujourd'hui ne vote
pour lui parce qu'ils veulent sortir
bolsona et ça ça va être un problème de
recherche
le Brésil et une jeune démocratie c'est
quand même un problème le le on le voit
dans d'autres pays
problématique qu'en fait le vote pour ça
devient un vote parce qu'en bon parce
qu'on ne veut pas l'autre nom de rejet
un mot sur justement la manière dont les
Brésiliens votent ce sont des urnes
électroniques chaque électeur doit donc
taper un code qui correspond à celui du
candidat un code à deux chiffres pour le
président par exemple les gouverneurs 3
pour les sénateurs j'explique parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident 4 pour
les députés fédéraux 5 pour les députés
de l'Assemblée de chaque État alors ce
système est bien sûr critiquer et
notamment critiqué par Jaïr bolsonaro
bolsonaro alors que ça fait longtemps
qu'il est utilisé par les Brésiliens lui
évoque des fraudes justement est-ce que
ça va être un vrai problème est-ce que
cette histoire de fraude Sylvia kapanema
risque de changer vraiment l'issue du
vote que effectivement lundi il décide
de ne pas se soumettre si effectivement
il perds qui est prévu ne pas ne pas
soumettre justement aux votes en disant
déjà aujourd'hui qu'il y a des fraudes à
cause du système et du complot qui
l'avance parce que le vote électronique
peut susciter des méfiance alors que
c'est un vote très sécurisé et pourquoi
il faut un voter les trucs sans que
scrutants comme vous avez dit et aussi
156 millions d'électeurs parce que le
vote au Brésil est obligatoire il a
l'abstention de nos présentations mais
le vote est obligatoire donc c'est c'est
pas obligatoire
à partir de 18 ans jusqu'à 65 70 oui 70
et donc il y a un en collège électoral
très important il y a un bon important
nombre pour ce temps et ça c'était une
des raisons même de fierté d'avoir
construit ce modèle d'élection dont les
résultats sortent une heure après il est
fiable il est surveillé il est très
fiable et bossonal qu'on dit le
questionne ça il lance il se lance dans
les polémiques de complot et de pour
pouvoir compter les résultats sauf que
une fois encore et là comme il y a 5
élections tous les députés les sénateurs
les gouverneurs qui vont être élus ils
vont pas vouloir non plus qu'on
questionne ses élections donc il est un
peu piégé déjà d'une part par le système
lui-même et aussi par toutes les
institutions qu'on défendu le système
électoral y compris au niveau
international on risque de se retrouver
quand même dans un scénario à la Trump
c'est-à-dire qu'on va voir quelle sera
la solidité de cette démocratie
brésilienne lundi alors d'abord il faut
remarquer que le système électoral
brésilien c'est une fierté nationale
donc c'est assez bizarre d'avoir le
président tout d'un coup qui arrive en
disant notre truc et même par rapport
aux États-Unis
électorale mais le deuxième point par
contre je partage pas l'optimisme de
l'analyse qui consiste à dire puisque
tous les autres sont élus ils ont pas
envie que l'élection soit remise en
cause puisque justement si on prend le
cap Trump ils ont été les républicains
ont été capables de contester l'élection
présidentielle sans contester l'élection
à la chambre donc voilà comme on est
dans des parties qui sont dans un pays
de la réalité ils sont très bien capable
d'expliquer que seul le vote
présidentiel a été truqué on en est ce
serait pas possible en fait très
honnêtement je pense que est-ce que par
exemple bolsonaro c'est s'il va inciter
un soulèvement ou pas moi je pense que
lui-même peut-être ne le sait pas en
fait tout va dépendre de la proportion
du scrutin s'il y a un vote majoritaire
est-ce qu'il osera comme ça lever ce
qu'il faut quand même voir on a eu un
test là il y a eu la fête nationale le 7
septembre le fils de bolsonaro donc il a
plusieurs fils dont un qui est quand
même le qui a le plus d'affaires aussi
derrière lui a quand même fait un tweet
ou pas pratiquement il faisait un appel
à prendre les armes donc c'est quand
même pas rien d'autant que ce fils donc
c'est Eduardo bolsonaro il était au
Capitole il était invité par la Trump ce
jour-là et en fait il est même resté
quand il y a eu l'intérêt la surrection
du 6 janvier et on voit bien que dans la
mouvance des soutiens de bolsonaran il y
a quand même un certain nombre de
supporters qui sont à peu près les mêmes
profils que ceux qui étaient au Capitole
et qui ont surtout envie de qui n'ont
pas le respect des institutions
démocratiques et ça c'est quand même un
vrai problème Gaspard Estrada ça veut
dire c'est qui qui pourrait faire en
fait qui pourra aller du côté de
bolsonaro des militaires ou pas par
exemple armée aurait quel type de de
position parce que d'après ce que j'ai
lu elle veut être maintenant un arbitre
alors qu'on sait que bolsonaro avait
vraiment l'électorat de l'armée il y a 4
ans oui elle a changé ou est-ce
qu'effectivement il pourrait y avoir des
militaires qui contesteraient aussi le
scrutin si effectivement une perdait
lundi on a très peu d'informations en
fait sur ce qui se passe dans les
casernes d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle normalement l'armée la grande
muette il se trouve que il se trouve que
aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'inquiète le
plus la circulation d'armes de manière
totalement sans contrôle le fait que
bolsonaro a libéré avec des décrets qui
est à libéralisé la vente d'armes à feu
et qu'il puisse avoir des militants de
bolsonaro qui voilà prennent armée il y
a déjà eu ma vie assassinat durant la
police
se sont fait tuer donc de ce point de
vue là c'est c'est quelque chose qui moi
me moi-même de sécurité est-ce que ça
peut se traduire par effectivement
l'asso de des symboles du symbole de la
démocratie brésilienne est-ce que
l'armée pourrait justement se joindre à
ce type d'assaut c'est vraiment à mon
avis le rôle de l'armée qui est en cause
dans un sens ou dans l'autre on verra
comment elle se positionne moi j'ai été
un petit peu inquiet parce que l'armée
ces derniers temps notamment certains
généraux eux-mêmes mis en cause le
processus électoral ce sont eux-mêmes
érigés en senseur de pouvoir vérifier la
solidité des urnes et ce genre de choses
qui est un peu bizarre parce qu'il y a
une justice électorale qui sert
précisément à ça au Brésil après sur la
question des armes je voudrais juste
revenir là-dessus effectivement elles
ont été libéralisées par bolsonaro mais
on est très loin de la situation
américaine et de l'autre côté les armes
ont toujours circuler au Brésil et s'il
y a 50000 morts violentes par an au
Brésil ça n'est pas parce par manque
d'armes donc de ce point de vue là les
conditions d'une insurrection entre
guillemets si on est sur juste sur le
plan de l'armement de la population
toujours existé ça c'est pas une grande
nouveauté justement comment est-ce qu'on
parle on passe des conditions de
l'insurrection à effectivement un coup
d'état parce que c'est ça en fait la
menace d'une démocratie et lorsqu'on dit
que bolsonaro est un nostalgique par
exemple de la dictature militaire est-ce
que ça pourrait basculer par exemple
après un scrutin comme celui-là oui il
vient de cette de la dictature militaire
elle fait apologie à plusieurs fois il a
il a dit plusieurs fois qu'il quitterait
par le pouvoir il a essayé sauf que de
l'autre côté ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que les institutions elles
refusent ça donc déjà la Cour suprême
aussi tous les milieux de la justice
avec les universitaires universités de
sang parle les universités de droits qui
ont fait un acte le 11 août dernier pour
défendre la démocratie et donc cette
défense de la démocratie elle elle est
quand même importante aujourd'hui dans
la société on sait pas de de coup d'état
existe et les menaces aussi des
rébellions ou de formes de contestation
qui peuvent être qui sont peut-être même
plus à imaginer qu'un coup de ta classe
classique selon toutes les analyses
qu'on liées actuellement donc on peut
s'inquiéter lundi et surtout si je peux
me permettre de d'ajouter sur le les
militaires je pense qu'effectivement
c'est difficile de de savoir comment ils
vont se comporter dans la mesure où il y
a un peu des courants distincts
différents et mais en même temps ce qui
est peut-être un peu rassurant c'est de
se dire ok la dictature
1964-85 avant la dictature les
militaires avaient un rôle très
important dans la société civile
brésilienne c'est eux qui faisaient un
peu la Polo voilà ils étaient présents
dans le jeu politique aujourd'hui ils
ont absolument pas ce rôle là ils sont
dans ils ont des places dans le
gouvernement mais ça c'est parce que ils
sont contents de les avoir mais ils
n'interviennent pas trop à part
effectivement
mis en avant après il faut pas à qui
profite le crime est-ce que vraiment
dans un Brésil ou quand même le le
problème la problématique après les
élections ça va être quand même de gérer
le Brésil qui est dans une situation
économique catastrophique donc quel est
l'intérêt aujourd'hui d'être plus
présent dans le pouvoir à part de garder
des postes oui ou ça peut être le
complexe du Sauveur de nous nous avons
les solutions tout le monde politique
est corrompu etc moi je pense que
effectivement les institutions
brésiliennes ont montré une grande
solidité sous le mandat de gerbol son
arrow c'était pas facile mais en même
temps les institutions socialistes il y
a des gens pour garder les institutions
donc s'il y a plus personne pour garder
la porte de la cour suprême la porte de
la cour suprême sera envahie par une
foule qui voudra extirper les juges et
faire sa propre justice donc voilà donc
la question c'est vraiment est-ce que la
police et l'armée vont rester du côté de
la légalité ou est-ce que elle pourrait
éventuellement basculer pour
éventuellement même dans une forme de
folie menée par quelques leaders donc ça
reste une question
mais je pense que c'est on peut
s'inquiéter ce qui va scénario
impossible et surtout moi je pense qu'il
faut plus s'inquiéter des milices parce
qu'on sait que les milices sont très
importantes et donc de toute cette
corruption aussi qui a qui intervère
avec la vie de la police de des
personnes qui sont censées incarner
l'ordre et qui en fait bon sont quand
même totalement corrompus je pense que
l'inquiétude elle est quand même plus là
que sur les militaires parce que en
revanche les mouvements de milice de
soutien de supporters avec armés etc
c'est là où on peut y avoir des
débordements alors dans le dans le type
inséréctionnel après est-ce que ça peut
aller jusqu'à ce qui s'est passé au
Capitole un symbole aussi fort un
renversement abrasia faut moi je pense
que pour le moment faut raisons garder
il y a quand même un candidat dans
l'élection qui est largement favori et
aujourd'hui
par les Amérindiens régulièrement donc
ils ont l'habitude d'être en veille
alors justement la transition est toute
faite avec les Amérindiens puisqu'on va
parler de la de l'Amazonie que quand
même un sujet donc on a pas tellement
entendu pendant cette campagne
il me semble très peu présent dans
comprends pas mais qui intéresse le
monde entier puisque c'est le poumon de
la planète et c'est l'une des images
d'ailleurs les plus marquantes pendant
le mandat de bolsonaro c'était celle de
celle de la pénombre en pleine
après-midi à ça au polo quand la
mégalopole s'est recouverte d'une
épaisse fumée parce qu'il y avait des
feux de forêt en Amazonie c'est vrai que
ça a beaucoup choqué on va écouter
justement bolsonaro c'était en septembre
il est faux de dire que l'Amazonie
appartient au patrimoine de l'humanité
c'est une fausse idée scientifique de
dire que les forêts amazoniennes sont
les poumons du monde
vous êtes un peu spécialiste du sujet
l'Amazonie
donc ça je suis très gêné
pas d'oxygène voilà donc simplement
l'Amazonie c'est un gros stock de
carbone et on préfère qu'il soit dans
les arbres en Amazonie plutôt que dans
l'atmosphère à contribué au changement
climatique donc ça c'est clair mais
après ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que l'Amazonie est plutôt un sujet pour
l'extérieur du monde enfin l'extérieur
du Brésil et pas tellement pour les
Brésiliens et ils n'ont pas non plus
complètement tort d'affirmer leur
souveraineté sur l'Amazonie voilà
bolsonaro si j'ai bien compris la
déforestation a été multipliée par deux
c'est ça donc c'est quand même un
problème enfin en tout cas d'ailleurs
vous avez parlé des populations
multiplié par deux elle est la moitié de
ce qu'elle était au début du
gouvernement lu là
et pendant le gouvernement Lula en
revanche il y a eu quand même protection
plus forte ça il peut je veux dire
le gouvernement Louna bon bilan sur le
plan de la déforestation ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il a un bon bilan sur toutes les
domaines de l'environnement après comme
je vous disais la déforestation a
beaucoup remonté sous bolsonaro mais on
n'est pas à des on n'est pas revenus au
niveau critique du début des années de
ville cela étant de toute manière chaque
kilomètre carré qui disparaît est un
problème pour le Brésil d'abord et pour
l'humanité quel problème alors puisque
vous dites que c'est pas le plus vendu
la planète juste dans le problème c'est
le c'est le carbone qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère donc chaque hectare de
forêt c'est 400 tonnes de carbone qui
vont dans l'atmosphère mathématiquement
et c'est surtout à mon sens quelque
chose qu'on oublie beaucoup mais c'est
de la biodiversité qui disparaît et une
bibliothèque du vivant qui disparaît
comme ça et pour le Brésil immédiatement
c'est probablement un changement
climatique qui va vers moins de
précipitations puisque la forêt
amazonienne émet beaucoup de vapeurs qui
va irriguer le sud de l'Amérique du Sud
et donc c'est probablement se tirer une
balle dans le pied c'est à dire avoir
moins de
et alors si on peut sur la déforestation
moi je pense qu'il y a quand même un
point important à souligner donc
aujourd'hui Lula il a mis dans son
programme de campagne et puis il a dit
que il agirait lui pour justement
retourner à une situation voilà
que cette déforestation ne continue pas
comme ça sur cette flambée encore une
fois il vous le rappelle lié justement
bolsonaro c'est pas le néronce je veux
dire il y a eu d'autres Pyroman c'est
peut-être le le pyromane en chef mais
malheureusement ça fait longtemps ça
fait des décennies que la déforestation
existe et que le problème aurait pu être
mieux traité et si je peux me permettre
d'ajouter ça parce que ça me semble
important c'est que nous d'ici on parle
toujours de le problème de la
déforestation à travers l'Amazonie c'est
un une problématique mais en fait au
Brésil on parle moins du Serrado et
c'est quand même cette partie là qui est
devenue totalement accaparée par
l'agriculture c'est là aussi où il y a
un problème de déforestation et dans la
promesse que fait que fait aujourd'hui
Lula de cesser la déforestation en tout
cas de ne plus arriver à des chiffres
catastrophiques comme ça je pense qu'il
arrivera peut-être à le faire parce que
en plus le l'Amazonie est sous les
projecteurs ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour lui de le faire dans le
cerado parce qu'il aura bien besoin
aussi d'avoir le soutien de
l'agrobusiness qui est un des lobbies
les plus importants et les plus
influents au Congrès et ça
malheureusement Lula il fera avec comme
il a fait dans ces mandats précédents
il faut trouver cet équilibre entre
effectivement la gros business donc le
développement du Brésil et puis la
protection de la nature on se retrouve
en fait avec ce type oui de Dilemme je
pense qu'il y a aussi une autre question
c'est comment faire en sorte que
l'agrébusiness évolue et je pense que de
ce point de vue là une des propositions
en tout cas qu'il a réalisé avec Marina
Silva qui est donc son ancienne ministre
de l'Environnement qui s'était brouillé
depuis une quinzaine d'années et qui
aujourd'hui soutient Lula à nouveau
c'est de réorienter en fait les
investissements de la banque de
d'investissement du Brésil la bnds vers
des investissements productif notamment
qui soit écologique et pour faire en
sorte de faire évoluer le modèle
économique de ces entreprises qui sont
dans le cerrado et dans d'autres
territoires limitrophes
quand même très fort de cet agrobusiness
il y a pas que le corporate business il
y a aussi le fait que le Parti des
Travailleurs historiquement a toujours
été en faveur du développement
économique et que la grève business est
un énorme levier au Brésil ils vont pas
s'en priver voir le seul quasiment non
alors justement malheureusement le
Brésil a aussi un petit peu oublié que
c'était une puissance industrielle et
que il était capable de vendre des
avions autant que de vendre des tonnes
de soja et pourquoi vous dites qu'il a
oublié parce que
c'est c'est secteurs là ont été moins
poussés notamment par le gouvernement et
le Brésil avait même manqué de vendre
son joyau national embraying ce qui
était quand même un petit peu un petit
peu bizarre là aussi initiative un petit
peu bizarre du gouvernement bolsonaro
mais sur le sur le plan de l'Amazonie
simple c'est très simple l'Amazonie
c'est un symbole comme je vous le dis
qui répercute à l'extérieur du Brésil
beaucoup plus qu'à l'intérieur du Brésil
et donc Lula est intelligent il voit
bien que diplomatiquement parlant c'est
millions de protéger l'Amazonie et que
ça va l'aider sur le plan diplomatique
la transition toute trouver décidément
ce soir vous êtes très bon pour me faire
mes transitions politiques
internationales justement il y a une
vraie différence entre bolsonaro et Lula
bolsonaro qui a quand même isolé le
Brésil du reste du monde et là qui est
un peu plus connu pour justement essayer
d'insérer le Brésil dans une communauté
internationale on va écouter Lola
nous allons recommencer à gouverner ce
pays
à faire de la question climatique une
priorité en d'autres termes il n'y aura
pas de terrain d'entente nous le
prendrons très au sérieux parce que nous
voulons prendre des engagements
internationaux nous voulons construire
des engagements internationaux donc ces
partenariats que nous voulons construire
pour préserver le climat sont très
sérieux et très importants
parce qu'on se souvient on a encore les
images de Lula faisant le tour du monde
voyant à peu près tout le monde et en
revanche je me le sauna on l'a vu à peu
près nulle part enfin il est peut-être
déplacé quoi dans une vingtaine de pays
sur pendant 4 ans enfin il y avait quoi
une espèce d'isolationnisme chez lui
affiché peut-être il le souhaitait pas
mais il a été isolé déjà par même par
ses partenaires politiques d'extrême
droite qui ne le qui voulait pas être
très à côté de lui parce que son image à
l'international est très mauvaise aussi
ça conduite des discours à l'ONU parce
que le Brésil fait bien sûr de l'ONU à
chaque fois et souvent il y avait des
choses absurdes qui étaient dites qui
étaient complètement hors protocole donc
bossonnade il n'a pas du tout suggéré
tout cela il a été en catastrophe
finalement le seul proche de lui c'était
Trump n'est plus au monde donc ça joue
aussi j'imagine
il est allé il faut quand même se
souvenir que bolsonaro et aller visiter
quelques jours avant la déclaration de
guerre on savait déjà que c'était tendu
avec l'Ukraine quoi il a fait une visite
exactement 6 jours avant avant
l'invasion russe et en Ukraine donc
c'est quand même de se fâcher avec les
Chinois qui sont quand même les plus
gros investisseurs et le plus gros
clients sur le plan agricole du Brésil
c'est quand même une bourde absolue une
bourde absolue
Gaspard extrada justement lui revendique
Lula une sorte de leadership régional en
Amérique du Sud et puis d'après ce que
j'ai lu c'est quand même le nationalisme
brésilien mais dans les institutions
internationales donc avec une volonté de
réformes du Conseil de sécurité une
volonté de mettre le Brésil au sein de
ces briques enfin voilà une espèce de
une politique internationale de
leadership si je puis dire oui bon lola
a toujours été une personnalité
internationale avant même d'être
président de la République par exemple
en France il avait des relations avec
Jospin avec Hollande avant même d'être
président donc c'est vrai que c'est je
pense que c'est une des figures
politiques qui sur le long terme a eu le
plus d'expérience internationales je
pense qu'aussi la circonstances du monde
d'aujourd'hui ont évolué entre sa sortie
du palais du planalton en 2010 et
aujourd'hui avec une affirmation de la
rivalité stratégique entre la Chine et
les États-Unis ce qui est objectif en
une problématique pour le Brésil
jusqu'à en 2010 voilà
l'insertion internationale du Brésil
était beaucoup plus simple puisque il
n'y avait pas justement cette rivalité
et et des pays tels que le Brésil qui
cherche à privilégier le
multilatéralisme et à diversifier les
partenariats n'avaient pas à choisir or
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit par exemple
des questions comme l'implantation de
réseau 5G qui oppose par emment Huawei
avec d'autres opérateurs
occidentaux il est clair qu'on ne peut
pas choisir deux opérateurs il faut
faire un choix et ça ce sera de mon
point de vue une des questions qui se
poseront si nous la arrive au pouvoir
c'est-à-dire comment faire en sorte de
préserver cette singularité de la
diplomatie brésilienne dans un contexte
international où les rivalités les
tensions augmentent où il y a une
logique de blocs peut-être plus forte
aussi c'est à dire
vers l'Afrique et de nouveau
partenariats et en même temps qui
faisait sa diplomatie il y avait aussi
des entreprises brésiliennes qui étaient
en Afrique avec un rôle important donc
c'est un peu notre notre diplomatie mais
effectivement il va falloir peut-être
qu'il choisisse son camp est-ce que par
exemple la Chine est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
devoir s'il est élu bien sûr choisir
Chine ou pachine sur les technologies
l'Amérique d'après ce que j'ai lu moi il
déjà pratiquement téléphoné à Biden en
disant aux Américains de dire tout de
suite dès qu'il sera élu si c'est le cas
d'afficher tout de suite le
sa victoire donc ça veut dire qu'il se
rapproche tout de même enfin qu'il a un
lien il peut avoir un lien fort avec
binden il va chercher à cultiver un
Forex byden et avec la Chine et ils vont
faire une politique d'équilibré après
moi je trouve que c'est pas très habile
ni des américains ni d'ailleurs de Lula
d'insister beaucoup sur cette relation
avec les Américains parce que ça donne
l'impression d'une élection qui est
téléguidée depuis Washington et les
admonestation des Américains sur des
élections transparentes au Brésil font
un peu un peu grand frère ce qui me
paraît pas une très bonne chose pourquoi
d'ailleurs il a demandé aux États-Unis
enfin moi je l'ai lu mais je savais pas
si donc c'est le cas oui oui il y a un
côté à la fois de vouloir être validé
par la première puissance mondiale
forcément ou en tout cas le pays qui
apparaît elle mais en même temps je
trouve que c'est pas très très bien vu
d'autant plus que en face il a un clan
qui est un petit peu nationaliste et
donc il donne des munitions par rapport
par rapport à problématique là donc
équilibriste c'est ça qui en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il sera plus proche
de la France que n'a été le mandat de
bolsonaro avec Macron on se souvient
voilà des sorties effroyables sur la
première dame voilà donc quand même
c'est on peut pas imaginer une période
plus tragique dans les relations
diplomatiques que celles qu'on a connu
la sous-gallo entre la France et le
Brésil quoi c'est alors que c'était il y
a quand même toute une histoire entre le
Brésil et la France donc pour le coup on
va on va arriver dans un autre cas de
figure si si encore une fois il était
favoris des sondages et élus on verra se
déplace en France il va avoir Macron et
va avoir un Mélenchon il va d'ailleurs
été proche à la fois c'est vrai ce que
vous dites de la gauche du Jospin etc de
de Hollande qui était venu pour le rio
plus 20 etc et aussi il était très
proche de Sarkozy ils sont restés voilà
on peut dire qu'il connaît à peu près
toute la classe politique française
il faudra qu'on se méfie un petit peu
j'ai peur que les positions de Lula ne
soient pas si francophiles qu'on peut
juste l'imaginer le Brésil a des visions
différentes et notamment sur l'Amazonie
il est possible que ces visions de
coïncident pas complètement avec les
nôtres et lors de la sortie du président
Macron en août 2019 au sommet du G7
Loula était sur la même ligne que
bolsonaros sur l'Amazonie éthano et
c'est nous qui allons décider ce qu'on
va en faire et il y a d'autres choses
Europe qui va être un jeu il veut
renégocier également je sais pas ce qui
va être fait franchement je ne sais pas
parce que pour l'instant
je l'ai pas mais ce dont on peut
craindre c'est que avec lui là l'Europe
va vouloir négocier et cet accord peut
être nocif donc il y a des choses je
commande du lave le travailler c'est
quelque chose qui va va attirer notre
attention ici et bientôt parce qu'il y a
les élections européennes aussi alors
les gens si je peux me permettre sur la
diplomatie je pense que quand même le
point clé c'est ce qu'on souligné tout à
l'heure c'est la Chine c'est le rapport
avec la Chine parce que pour le coup
c'est le premier partenaire économique
et va bien falloir prendre des positions
qui qu'on observera assez vite voilà
s'il gagne bien sûr les jeux les jeux ne
sont pas ne sont pas faibles bien sûr
donc dans ce duel entre là et
bolsonaro on aura bien sûr la réponse
lundi matin même avant d'ailleurs
dimanche soir me semble-t-il puisque
d'après ce que vous dites on a les
résultats très rapidement donc on verra
comment si effectivement il gagne sachez
que le second tour aura lieu sia second
tour le 30 octobre c'est aucun candidat
donc n'obtient la majorité absolue au
premier tour merci en tout cas à tous
les quatre Sylvia kavanema merci
beaucoup Virginie Jacob merci François
Michel Letourneau et puis merci beaucoup
à vous Gaspard extrada merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis et rester avec nous
sur France 24
[Musique]